[Musique]
et on débute cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie pour ce weekend
Gabrielle et on commence avec un
événement à Versailles oui on commence
avec un petit blind test Mathilde est-ce
que vous reconnaissez ce
[Musique]
titre écrit par John lon
1969 et si je vous parle des Beatles
Mathilde c'est que le célèbre groupe
britannique reprend vie le temps d'une
semaine à Versailles au cyano au
programme des vendredis une comédie
musicale construite avec des reprises du
groupe samedi c'est une comédie sur un
monde parallèle où les Beatles
n'auraient jamais existé qui est proposé
à noté également un concert live avec
l'un des groupes homage officiel de boot
leg Beatles tout droit venu de Londres
et cet événement Mathilde il est
organisé pour le 60e anniversaire du
passage des Beatles dans la ville
c'était le 15 janvier 1964 au Crano de
Versailles c'était d'ailleurs leur
premier concert en France c'était leur
premier concert en France premier
concert en France d'accord on poursuit
en en musique Gabriel mais dans un style
un peu différent oui on passe du rock à
la house et même à la hardard techno
avec un événement qui a lieu à la
batterie de Guy enc au programme une
soirée techno avec des DJ du terr
parmi les artistes château brillant la
terrasse ou encore Drax rendez-vous
demain soir dès 20h à la batterie du
théâtre maintenant au pristhme
d'élancour après avoir joué partout en
France la Comédia d' la Bliss et de
passage dans les ivelines oui et la
compagnie de spectacle propose samedi
soir la pièce péri colossau de Gérard
Levoyer une comédie à la fois romantique
et dramatique qui invite à la réflexion
on écoute l'un des comédiens au micro de
michaelll elmidoro c'est une petite
histoire d'amour entre deux
personnages qui ont à peu près une
vingtaine d'années de de différence et
un peu aigri par par la vie de tous les
jours et un sujet traité avec avec
humour et gravité en même temps pour
découvrir le spectacle rendez-vous au
prisme d'élancour c'est samedi des 20h
et jusqu'au 11 février 2024 la danse est
à l'honneur sur le territoire de Grand
Paris saéoise avec la la 4e bienénale de
la danse oui et pour cette année
olympique près de 40 événements sont
organisés répartis sur 16 communes deux
événements ont retenu mon attention ce
weekend une exposition à mantelaville
intitulé entrer dans la danse qui
explore le lien étroit entre le sport et
la danse avec une attention portée à
tous les types de danse du hip hop au
breaking en passant par la danse
contemporaine et la danse classique
autre rendez-vous ce weekend à HR avec
un spectacle où l'art de la danse et le
basket évolue ensemble et on termine vos
idées de sortie Gabrielle avec du cirque
du cirque à l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline durant tout le
mois de janvier dans son spectacle
l'absolu Boris JB combine acrobatie
danse et question existantiel tout ça
évoluant dans un gigantesque silo conçu
pour l'occasion loin du chapito
traditionnel cette configuration permet
au public un angle d'observation inédit
promettant une expérience originale ou
ça a l'air int effectivement merci
beaucoup Gabriel pour toutes ces idées
de sortie